I'm Gloria Borger and you're watching PewNews :3
*PAPAPAPA*
Good evening! I'm Gloria Borger today. We have a lot of news to discuss, so let's just stop
anyyway our first story comes from Johnny Dee, luckily
As we reported last week Johnny D. Was hospitalized because he suffered from Noumea, Pneu
Nouméa pneumonia johnny is now back. He's looking better and he made a response video. They do not choose to show yourself on YouTube
Like I do.They're very good. I wish I was as good as them. If you come to my town, I'll show you where to go
I'll show you we can see, the best rappers, the best singers in this city
This is so sweet
He will show you if you're in his town Johnny D invites you to show his favorite rapper it's wonderful to see
First of all how much support you guys sent to the GoFundMe page it hit the goal
$15,000 an amazing effort good job everyone
I'm really proud to see how empathetic and heartwarming and
This community of Squad fam can be and it's really nice to see Johnny D. Just genuinely being grateful in return
Next news this week a female empowerment
Movement was announced and it's called bully hunters and as soon as I heard about bully hunter initiative
I thought to myself there is just no way this could go wrong
Whatsoever this is not gonna end up like another train wreck
How is this real?
2018 is just wonderful, it just keeps on giving so the idea behind bully hunters
is that uh,
to stop harassment in games,
specifically Counter Strike or CS GO, you can call upon a bully hunter that will then join your game and kill the bully in the
game.They display this in the most hilariously awkward and most scripted way I've ever seen. Now our bully
Hunter has asked "therosethorn" live in game, who is harassing her and our victim
Then immediately replied. Let's zoom in again on the bottom left-hand corner.
Now you see there, the tool connected these two, a victim with a bully hunter
Okay, so now "Bully Hunter_77" knows the name of the harasser, and she is ready to take action. Now
We are going to switch over to BULLY HUNTER_77's screen
to watch the hunt,
cut to that feed, please and play it.
So we are watching our bully hunter. She knows who the harasser is and she's on the hunt
You can still hear the harassment in the background, it doesn't stop
So now, BULLY HUNTER_77 is looking for the harasser, and it looks like she's going to use her knife and there it is, just pause right there
Let's back up and see that again.
A brilliant knife move, very difficult, that's right knifing someone back in cs:go while they're standing still or probably have left their computer
It's one of the most difficult moves of all time. This is supposed to stop harassment everyone
This is what their idea even if this wasn't
Completely fake and staged it's still a terrible idea. See in the lower left hand corner. Let's pause that and zoom into that
Our bully hunter left the calling card message to the harasser harassment is not a game bully org
We sure showed him everyone
Loved the music that they added, hahaha
We've been waving text from the bullies the harassment has been taken care of
This is our casual gamer
Pink light 23 who has been harassed in game a pink like 23 what you're gonna
Do is you're gonna sit here and play Counter Strike and when the light shows at you?
That means you've been harassed so be sure to maybe show some sort of emotion
You can cry if you want to now. Let's see how she used our global tool to call a bully hunter
They have an audience reacting to it. Do they not understand that this illegitimate is their whole point
If their goal is to show that harassment is real
And which I'm not denying by the way they just create the off
That if fake now if you're not for some reason surely. This is fake
Basically they even discovered that bully hunter 77 is the same person that was being bullied
they literally just changed the name on this team profile, which you can see by looking at them and
It's just so laughably bad
It reminds me of so many times
I work with agencies
But especially back in the past where they are just so extremely tone-deaf to what is a good idea
And what is not a good idea because they never actually made anything online, so they don't know how?
people are going to perceive these sort of things and
This is just one of those ideas that for some reason no one said no to
steal serious which one of the brands that was involved and
when they got call out on all of this their response was if the only thing that comes of this is a
Conversation around the topic then we feel it is still a step in the right direction
Stop we need to I'm tired of hearing this argument
If only we did one step for women
Then it's a step that is worth taking no okay. You did more harm than good here clearly
This is so idiotic that no one is going to take harassment seriously
That's how stupid it is so don't pretend that you took a step forward. This is taking a step back and for what selling headphones
Great fantastic initiative you got there wait
Companies need to stop using charity as some sort of ploy to seem as good moral beings you're not you're just morons
Everyone involved with this is immoral proceeds from this will go to support victims of harassment in gaming
What does that mean?
Who-who who could that possibly go to I
Have a victim of harassment in gaming okay, can I please have some of the SteelSeries money?
I I could really use this one of the hosts involved the tweeted out that it was never supposed to be taken as
Happening live. Here's the script. Oh, okay, so because you shared the script that means all the sudden that
It wasn't supposed to be scripted right oh my god. I can't begin to count the hours
I've spent gaming online in that time. I have seen every imaginable sort of harassment and threatening language
And yes, I have even used some of that language myself
No, no you can't play the victim card
You're just being criticized like everyone else can be on the Internet
We need to stop giving away pity as a currency to these people they literally feed off it
You're being criticized just because some people are being rude online doesn't make the fact that you messed up any less, okay?
No, no one deserves to be harassed
I'm not ignoring that that's the thing I've seen videos of
Other twitch streamers that probably would have been more appropriate to have hosting this event by the way
Yes, it is a problem. This certainly doesn't fix it, but hilarious nonetheless I
Tell you guys ass is coming out on Nintendo's switch, I check it out link it or skip you
You know you don't want to miss this. This is a game of the year everyone
Our next story comes from Eppie Faria Twitter user so I'm watching Peter pie on YouTube because I'm trash no no no
Don't self-deprecating right you're an intellectual
nothing less
I'm greeted with an ADD of dancing chick titled hot girl 2018 and this thumbnail
What we're of course going to censor this there's no way I would ever show something this bad on my channel
I want everyone that watches my videos to feel safe at all times
so
We will censor this of course. I feel like it for years now. I play this game with YouTube or everyone where
It's it's as okay, so if you want mid-roll ads you're gonna have to make the video ten minutes
That's just a rule okay fine
All right
If you want any sort of decent ads make sure or none age restriction make sure you don't swear and use the explicit language
Fine okay sure I also make sure you don't have any explicit content jokes or a controversial topic okay fine
Okay great here is your head
It's straight up pork
Thank you. Thank you so much now. I noticed my CPM dropping a few weeks ago, and I try to understand why this happened
That's why I especially try to really cut down on swearing and this sort of thing hasn't done anything at all
And then you see these ads show show up, and it's it's pretty damn frustrating
It really feels like I slap in the face
YouTube's responded and took down this ad very quickly which I commend him for thank you for doing that but there was the same thing
Going on last week there was like a Vigano in one of my thumbnails of an ad and it's just like why
How is this happening how far is this gonna stretch? How far is this gonna go anyway next news everybody
Our last news come from Jacques himself that's right. He's back
He had to testify in front of the Congress you probably saw this because of privacy issues and concerns and those are of course
important topics to discuss
but I wanted to focus on some other questions that came up through this that I found a lot more interesting enticing with what we
Talked about earlier here, which is harassment or hate speech rather
Zuckerberg was
Asked to define hate speech for example senator. I think that this is a really hard question
And I think it's one of the reasons why we struggle with it. I'm worried about the psychological categories around speech
40% of Americans under age 35 tell pollsters
They think the First Amendment is dangerous
Because you might use your freedom to say something that hurts somebody else's feelings as we as we were able to
technologically shift especially having AI
proactively look at content
I think that that's gonna
Create massive questions for society about what obligations we want to require companies to yeah, you're right Zucc
the AI
determination of what's
Harmful content has really worked out really well as here over on YouTube
But so I don't see any problem with that their social media platforms are not neutral platforms
But bear some responsibility for the content. I agree that we're responsible for the content
Previously, It's been up in the air whether Facebook is a neutral
platform or if they are responsible for the content and to admit this it sort of changed is the whole dynamic of the.. things
Obviously, they're a private company. They're free to do whatever they want if they want to censor content
They are open to do so but previously it hasn't really been clear
Are you a free platform, or do you censor content, or do you shape or control?
What's posted on your site?
And is this is same sort of struggle that's going on here on YouTube where whether YouTube want it to be or not they are
Responsible for what's on their website. It's an interesting question to me
Because now that you have these massive companies like Google and Facebook
controlling such massive means of communication and important means of communication
It's is it within their right to censor that communication, or do they even have to do
It are they they've sort of forced into a corner to do it we see a lot of ideas being
Censored on YouTube and Facebook because they're not popular with the media
They have such a massive control over what sort of ideas are acceptable and not and that to me is a lot scarier than this
Whole issue with privacy that apparently this
Meeting was all about and if this continues in the future who knows what kind of implications it will have
That was it for this week's PewNews
Hope you enjoyed this video and their many ads that she was shown many great if you didn't have any ads, please
consider buying a mug
It would really help me out a lot, a PewNews Mug check out the link in the description
I am Gloria Borger, and this is me signing off
Now that's what this is all about removing harassment from gaming harassment has no place here